well
[Music]
hello, how are you, jaramillo is installed with
the most outstanding headlines for
today, Tuesday, November 24, Nevada
registered more than a thousand new cases by
cover night fin in the last 19 of 20
days yesterday the state registered more than 2,300
cases and six  deaths hospitalized patients
due to the virus also
continue to rise setting
records this month due to the increase in
cases the new measures invited by
the governor begin today
restaurants and bars must limit
capacity to 25 percent either inside
or outside the establishment
public gatherings will only be up to
50 people while private gatherings will be
limited to no more than 10 people
belonging to no more than two households
the mandatory use of masks remains
in place both inside venues
and outdoors these
implemented measures will last for a period  In three
weeks,
the Golden Knights announced that four
of their players tested positive after
testing.  Based on the detection of the virus, it is
important to mention that these players
did not participate in the food fair
yesterday, the team said that the
infected are isolated and complying with
the quarantine period and now we turn
to the weather forecast, we will see
temperatures around 60 degrees for
the rest of the week with some breezes
in the valley have a nice day I
'm I went out Jaramillo and this was your short
news bulletin in Spanish
[Music]